es difícil pronosticar hasta dónde puede
llegar la situación en brasil el supremo
tribunal federal apoyó que el senado
pueda investigar omisiones en la gestión
de la pandemia por parte del presidente
ya ir bolsonaro este como respuesta
aviso de que el país está cerca de
estallar amigos amigos del tribunal
supremo federal pronto vamos a tener una
crisis enorme estoy amenazando a nadie
pero creo que pronto tendremos problemas
serios
que saldrá de todo esto hasta dónde
vamos a llegar
parece que brasil es un barril de
pólvora y batalla política mientras la
situación de salud preocupa cada vez más
expertos aseguran que la variante
brasileña conocida como p 1 es incluso
más contagiosa que la detectada en el
amazonas a finales de 2020 un poco se
infectó por lo que una persona puede
infectar a muchas más personas sin duda
la variante p 1 es más transmisible eso
es indiscutible tu maestro es visible e
inés cuchillo una variante que está
disparando los casos entre los vecinos
de brasil y que podría llegar a evadir
los anticuerpos por las mutaciones
en argentina manifestantes se
concentraron frente a la embajada
brasileña con lemas como zepa bolsonaro
peligro mundial bueno gracias se ha
transformado un poco en un símbolo de la
desidia con un gobierno que desconoce
completamente la crisis sanitaria que
existe política salud y pobreza unos 27
millones de personas viven por debajo
del umbral de la pobreza en brasil la
asociación g-10 favelas trata de
combatirla este miércoles llegaron con
30.000 toneladas de alimentos a las
favelas de sao paulo estamos viviendo en
un brasil de hambre parte de la gente se
queda en casa otra hace la oficina en
casa y otra se muere de hambre en casa
una situación crítica que está aislando
al país con cada vez más estados
cerrando las conexiones aéreas es el
caso de francia que recibió este
miércoles los últimos aviones
procedentes de brasil